Aka spider-man aka the spider menace
unrest assured dear viewer good night
Welcome back everyone this will be my spider-man
no way home post credit scene video hopefully
you've had a chance to see the movie if you're
brand new to the channel be sure to subscribe
to get all the videos there is a lot that we have
to talk about a lot of big reveals and setups for
future spider-man movies at the end so careful
for spoilers if you have not seen spider-man no
way home yet because we're literally talking about
everything that happens in the post-credits scenes
but the first post-credit scene or the mid-credit
scene starts while the final battle is actually
finishing like right as big spoiler warning
again one more spoiler warning tom holland's
spider-man is fighting the green goblin their
big final battle and gets help from tobey maguire
spider-man who stops him from killing green goblin
from going super dark but because doctor strange's
special magic box that was containing the first
spell that got out of control that got messed
up explodes the fabric of reality starts tearing
around them with those big purple tears they get
bigger and bigger and bigger and dr strange can't
stop everybody from the multiverse who knows a
version of peter parker from coming into the mcu
universe you start to see thousands and thousands
of blue figures start to appear and getting ready
to walk through the purple tears like one of them
actually looks like the watcher from the what if
series which i'll talk about when i talk about the
doctor strange 2 trailer because it kind of seems
like we're getting a version of doctor strange
supreme from what if during doctor strange 2
but right as peter is getting the idea that
they should do a second spell to sort of erase all
knowledge of peter parker from everyone's memory
in the mcu and hopefully that will close the tears
it does successfully it doesn't completely fix
everything and it doesn't erase the first spell it
just kind of overwrites it a little bit the reason
why all the tobey maguire and andrew garfield
characters and villains came to the mcu is because
they knew a version of peter parker so when the
second spell makes them forget peter parker it
sort of negates the effects of the first spell so
that's why everybody starts getting sent back with
those flashes of yellow light at the end of the
movie but while they're still figuring that out
while the spell is getting started they pick up
at a bar in mexico with venom eddie brock in this
poor bartender that has to put up with him his
hat literally says mexico on it to let you know
where this is taking place and he's wearing the
same outfit that he was in the venom look to be
carnage post credit scene getting super drunk at
a bar wherever his hotel room was right before he
got teleported to the mcu so it sort of confirms
where he was at the end of venomolot to be carnage
in that post-credit scene if you missed that when
they bailed to mexico now we know at the end of
that movie they went to a beach and then later the
venom symbiote was explaining the history of its
race to eddie and how they had this hive mind that
was connected across the entire multiverse their
memories also went back to the creation of their
race when it was getting ready to show eddie some
of these memories from across the multiverse there
was now a similar yellow flash of light that's the
same effect you saw when the sinister six villains
tobey maguire ander garfield's versions of
spider-man were sent back home to their original
universes by doctor strange's second spell
so the idea is that venom was teleported to the
mcu because this venom symbiote like the new main
one remembered the tobey maguire peter parker
spider-man from spider-man 3 because their hive
mind meant that it had access to the memories
of the topher grace venom symbiote that's why
he got teleported to the mcu before the j jonah
jameson broadcast put peter parker on the screen
tom hardy's eddie brock only learned about peter
parker himself after he saw the j jonah jameson
broadcast and that was when they were inside the
mcu and if the spell only brought people to the
mcu who already knew who peter parker was it's
the hive memories of the topher grace venom that
it had access to that brought them to the mcu so
it kind of confirms that theory everybody had this
theory that oh he knew peter parker and that's
why he licked the screen because he had access
to the memories from the topher grace venom from
another universe and that's why he said that guy
also at the beginning of the movie doctor strange
is yelling at spider-man saying that he changed
his spell six times spider-man says actually i
changed it five times i think the idea is that
the five was supposed to represent the sinister
six films in the sixth was supposed to represent
venom even though technically if you take it
literally they're both wrong there were eight
people that got teleported into the mcu if you
include venom tobey maguire and andrew garfield's
versions of spider-man so if you're confused
about the timeline of all this like when is
everybody getting teleported to and from the mcu
it sounds like based on what tobey maguire and
andrew garfield said them only being in the mcu
for about a day or so that's about how long all
these characters were inside the mcu before doctor
strange performed the second spell to send them
all back and that's why the venom symbiote started
screaming no we just got here when he also starts
to get teleported back to the original venom
universe but while eddie and venom are getting
drunk at this bar he's talking to the bartender
about the events of the infinity saga of marvel
movies avengers infinity war thanos the infinity
stones they have this funny conversation about
the infinity gauntlet avengers end game like the
bartender basically does the luis thing recapping
the mcu for him i know we're still waiting for
them to release that ant-man and the wasp video
of luis recapping the mcu so eddie starts going on
all drunk going let me get this straight in this
universe there are superheroes all over the place
there was a guy in a tin suit talking about iron
man and the bartender does this little hail mary
to honor his death during avengers end game he
says there was a big green guy then the bartender
corrects him the hulk the bartender kind of gets
pissed with him going on and on correcting him
while he's just spouting about the avengers and
thanos eddie starts yelling about aliens and the
infinity stones saying you think that aliens like
stones aliens don't like stones because he's
talking about the symbiotes they're aliens too
the funny thing is that tobey maguire also
referenced the venom symbiote earlier in the
movie when they were all together talking about
the weirdest villains that they all face in their
original universes he said oh you know i fought
an alien once too it was a lump of black goo
the bartender yells at eddie about how his family
got snapped for five years and then he feels
kind of remorseful like wow five years that's a
long time saying that maybe we should go to new
york city and talk to this spider-man but because
they're so drunk the venom symbiote has also been
getting drunk with eddie they say oh it's time
for skinny dipping and as he gets up to go to the
ocean that's when he gets teleported back in this
big flash of light screaming no we just got here
like the venom symbiote was really excited to be
inside the mcu the bartender yelling about how he
still hasn't paid his bar tab as he disappears
like i'm never getting paid on this but it's
revealed that a tiny piece of the venom symbiote
gets left behind like a tiny lump of black goo
and that's their teaser for a spider-man symbiote
saga in the mcu in these future sequels that
they're planning with tom holland like eventually
through various means this version of the symbiote
will make its way to spider-man and it'll be kind
of like a combination of what you saw in the tobey
maguire spider-man 3 movie with that symbiote and
the original comic book secret wars origin for the
alien costume originally during the secret wars
origin story he found this small lump of black
goo while he was with the fantastic four on the
beyonder's battle world and it just covered him
creating the black costume then a couple years
later when they created the venom character they
retconned this adding the venom symbiote backstory
to it too like oh it wasn't just an alien costume
it was also a symbiote as well so because they
have a new fantastic four movie coming up and
the theory is that they're the ones who bought the
avengers tower like it's going to become the new
baxter building in the mcu spider-man might cross
over with a fantastic four in a future movie and
because they're doing a new spider-man trilogy
of movies with tom holland like they're starting
work on spider-man 4 pretty soon according to
amy pascal they'll probably use at least one or
more of those sequel movies in the new trilogy to
do an mcu version of the symbiote saga the reason
why they're really ambiguous about what's going
on with this small lump of the symbiote here like
is it the symbiote itself or is it like a spawn
of the symbiote is very similar to the way the
carnage symbiote came into existence carnage was
a piece of the venom symbiote mixed with cletus
cassidy's blood becoming a brand new version
of the symbiote like they called it a spawn
of the symbiote so the marvel people just want
to be ambiguous enough so they leave themselves
room to do whatever they want to with this new
version of the venom symbiote inside the mcu
they can say that this venom is slightly different
from the original venom and because the voice of
each symbiote is actually done by the actors
themselves like tom hardy does the voice of
the main venom symbiote woody harrelson also
did the voice of the carnage symbiote too it's
likely that when tom holland's spider-man gets the
symbiote tom holland will also do the voice of his
venom symbiote tom holland and tom hardy have both
told us about the spider-man vs venom crossover
movie that sony has been planning with marvel for
a while now and even though eddie got teleported
back to his original universe they can always
either bring him back from that universe or use a
different eddie variant inside the mcu for another
tom hardy crossover but based on what they've told
us we'll see venom 3 in spider-man 4 before we see
spider-man symbiote saga and what they might do is
spider-man 4 will probably just be some brand
new story with a bunch of different villains
they might just tease the symbiote saga with the
symbiote at the end of spider-man 4. if they were
going to give tom hall and spider-man the symbiote
in spider-man 4 this scene probably would have
been taking place in new york city like oh the
symbiote is already right next door to spider-man
this just gives them a little more room to figure
this out in the next couple of years like okay
this is what we want to do with this venom
saga inside the mcu so post all your theories
about when they'll give tom hall and spider-man
this version of the symbiote there is a second
post-credits scene i'll do a separate video for
it because it's actually kind of more of a legit
trailer for doctor strange 2 multiverse of madness
and it's like they just attached a trailer to the
end of spider-man no way home that video will post
next they kind of tease the doctor strange supreme
from the what if series is going to be the main
villain of the movie so i'll explain what's going
on with that also with a giant eyeball tentacle
creature which looks like schumachorth but it's
actually a different character called gargantos so
i'll explain what's going on with that that video
will post next make sure you have alerts enabled
for my channel so you don't miss that i'll do
my full breakdown video and easter eggs for the
entire movie after that and then i've got a bunch
of other bonus videos planned for the next week
there'll be a lot of spider-man things that we
need to talk about in the next week everyone click
here for that doctor strange 2 trailer video i'll
update the link as soon as i post that video later
and click here for my full spider-man no way home
review thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!